For decades, their logos were everywhere,
from local arenas to museums and concert halls.
Kodak, Xerox, and Baush and Lomb
were integrated into the core of the city.
Their executives played key roles on civic boards,
helping to shape local policies and initiatives
and other employees contributed at the grassroots level.
When these companies retreated,
it created not only an economic vacuum,
but also a cultural one.
Beyond the office walls, these companies
had long supported local culture and philanthropy.
So when their pockets dried up,
there was a noticeable void.
Cultural institutions like the Rochester Philharmonic,
the George Eastman Museum, and local galleries
suddenly had to make do with less.
Some scaled back while others scrambled
for new sources of funding.
This led to fewer exhibits, performances,
and opportunities for local artists to showcase their work.
For decades, many people in the Rochester area
followed a similar path.
Graduate high school or college get hired
by one of the big three, work there for life,
and retire with a good pension.
When these job paths collapsed,
many started to question the idea
of corporate loyalty altogether.
Work became more about adaptability than security.
People began changing careers,
starting their own businesses,
and even leaving the city entirely.
The community shifted around,
and in some ways became unstable,
but also more open to reinvention.